Moammar Ghadafi toppled a king to seize
power he outmaneuvered his opponents for
40 years and in one of his final TV
appearances he pretended to play chess
with the Russian and hoy many thought he
was deluded eccentric but he was cunning
enough to hold on to power long after
many dictators have been overthrown
he went from international pariah to
Western ally but the new relationship
didn't last and British bombs helped
drive him out of power Colonel Gaddafi
called himself brother leader after
coming to power in 1969 in a military
coup he was just 27 when he deposed King
Idris he went on to invent a new
political philosophy jamahiriya a
strange mix of socialism nationalism
Islam and his own ideas in reality he
was just another brutal dictator force
descent of home and abroad in 1984 his
age inspired any demonstration outside
the Libyan embassy in London
WPC Oh horn Fletcher was killed it was
one incident among the many which led
President Reagan to dub him the mad dog
the colonel sponsored terrorism around
the world arming among others the IRA
the PLO and Peru's Shining Path movement
in 1986 the US bombed
Gaddafi's Tripoli compound in revenge
for Libya's role in the attack on a
Berlin nightclub which had killed two
American servicemen two years later 270
people were killed when a Pan Am
passenger jet blew up over Lockerbie two
Libyan agents were charged and the eve
of the trial in Scotland skies James
Matthews posed the question which is
still not been answered whether two men
as has been reported acting under direct
orders from you despite never admitting
Libya's guilt the regime took
responsibility and paid compensation in
order to get years of sanctions lifted
things changed Tony Blair came to visit
Gaddafi gave up his weapons of mass
destruction I mean this is something
that is good in terms of acting against
terrorism good for our two countries in
terms of defence and also good for
business too the man jailed for the
Lockerbie bombing Abdel Basset al
Megrahi
was released by the Scottish government
on compassionate grounds Gordon Brown
denied a deal had been done with the
colonel for the decision angered the
White House when protests over his rule
broke out the Colonel's reaction was
instinctive
ruthless acts of suppression and then as
the rebellion grew absolute defiance
Wow think about the medical love you
could he call those opposing him rats
and vowed to hunt them down
it's street by street house by house and
then gazenga zhang gazenga alleyway to
alleyway ha ha ha
with benghazi about to be overrun a UN
resolution paved the way for
international military intervention when
NATO started bombing they could never
win the ratsy vowed pursue began to
close in on him it took six months and
while NATO bombed foreign forces trained
the rebels eventually they made a
triumphant entry into the capital
Tripoli
that's the sign nothing all makes when
they talk about kakadu 69 year old ex
dictator was reduced to ranting audio
messages in which he insisted he would
prevail the next time a British prime
minister visited Libya
it was the celebrating his part in
Gaddafi's down for David Cameron French
President Nicolas Sarkozy were greeted
his hero pictures and the statues were
hauled down throughout the country for
six weeks the man himself proved elusive
how the people who once lived in terror
of his regime have their final
recognition in woods at Sky News